good morning to you we start with
breaking news reaching us of large
explosions heard in Ukraine's Capital
City Kiev in the last half an hour
President Putin preparing to meet his
Security Council in the coming hours
following a blast on the bridge to
Crimea which is called an act of
terrorism by Ukraine while our defense
and security editor Deborah Haynes is
with us Deborah good morning what's
going on
so it's in the last hour these reports
have been breaking about several
explosions in the center of key if you
remember the capital came under heavy
bombardment at the start of the war but
there's been relative calm there in
recent months so this is very unusual to
have strikes right in the Heart of the
City where government offices are we
don't yet have confirmation yet of what
has been hit and whether there have been
casualties but for example an advisor to
the president has tweeted just now
um calling Russia a terrorist State
again and
um with a photograph of flames behind a
building the EU ambassador to Ukraine
has also tweeted a picture of central
Kiev with smoke rising in the background
clearly a very serious number of strikes
have hit the capital this morning and
it's at a time when Ukraine was bracing
itself for a response from Russia
following that strike that it for those
attacks the explosions that you
mentioned on the Kirch uh straight
bridge that bridge that connects the
Crimean Peninsula with the Russian
Mainland it was hit by explosions over
the weekend uh the Russian president is
going to be holding a National Security
Council meeting today and this is what
he said about that attack last night
there's no doubt it was a terrorist act
directed at the destruction of
critically important civilian
infrastructure of the Russian Federation
and the authors perpetrators and those
who ordered it are the special services
of Ukraine
foreign
still with us um Deborah just hearing
um several dead and injured in Kiev
well unfortunately that's not a surprise
with strikes of this magnitude it's
clearly a a long-range large missile
strike that's hit the capital it would
have had to have penetrated the capitals
very significant and well tested now air
defense systems and going into the
center of the city there are people
residential blocks there as well as
government offices and unfortunately I
imagine as the top as the hours pass
we'll get more details of exactly how
many have been injured and potentially
killed
okay thanks so much indeed thank you
joining us now working pensions Minister
Victoria Apprentice just want to talk
about what's happening in Kiev to start
with you you've been haven't you yes so
support
um key of um refugees who are here yes I
was there almost exactly a year ago it
was the most beautiful city well I'm I'm
sure it still is and it's just awful to
hear the news this morning we've got a
young woman who lives with us who's been
with us since March and she lives in
Kiev normally and has the Airaid siren
on her telephone which goes off in our
house and in my constituency in Banbury
and it's really chilling to hear the
news today actually and I thought for
those that are in Kiev at the moment yes
Aaron zapparija overnight was attacked
again it is it is still you know we are
still in the absolute midst of war and
we've heard some Dreadful stories over
the weekend her grandparents are living
in their Cellar in Curson they come up
in the daytime but they sleep in the
cellar and they don't actually know
whether they voted or not in the recent
referendum a Russian soldier with a gun
came to the door and they filled in
papers but they what they meant they
don't know and it's it's quite salutary
I think for us to remember what is
actually happening at the moment how
appropriate was it do you think for the
destruction of the bridge that uh
connects uh Crimea and Russia because he
was always going to react to that well I
don't think the ukrainians have taken
responsibility for that destruction so
we have to be very careful I think we
don't know who was responsible for it in
the Ukrainian mind that bridge was
quite an aggressive act in itself
because it linked Crimea to to
um Russia so the ukrainians or certainly
the ones who we know don't like that
bridge but I don't think we know who was
responsible for blowing it up and he is
speaking to his security team this
morning uh President Putin he has
threatened on more than one occasion
um the prospect of a nuclear attack what
would you say to him
well I think
it's this is a really worrying time for
globally really I I'm sure that we in
this country have done the right thing
by the ukrainians both by taking them in
but also very importantly by supporting
them militarily it's absolutely right
that we should continue to stand with
the ukrainians against this Russian
aggression and I really hope that we can
de-escalate
one of the byproducts of uh the war in
Ukraine of course is the energy Supply
both through Europe and indeed to the UK
as well
um it's causing all sorts of problems
for people here in the United Kingdom
going forward especially going into the
winter why isn't the government uh
offering an advice campaign an ad
campaign to tell us what to do to try to
save energy
well it's something that we're thinking
about but at the moment we don't think
we need to spend a lot of public money
on a campaign like that the reason for
that is really that we are very lucky
particularly when you look at other
places in Europe which don't have the
security of energy Supply that we have
we're only about 20 percent reliant on
on the Imports of of gas in this country
so we're we're fairly secure the the
National Grid who advise on this have
said that we have a buffer and we're
pretty certain that we will have enough
energy to go through the winter I mean
certainly the environmentalist in me
says for goodness sake turn the lights
off when you leave a room and use energy
very carefully of course I do and that's
the way I've brought my children up to
behave and and that's the way that I
would hope people could be but I don't
think we need to frighten people and
what I'm really worried about is that
older people and vulnerable people do
need to put the heating on and need to
still able to do that so so we have to
get the balance right with the messaging
yeah pretty certain isn't definite
though is it I mean well I think in this
world very little is definite but the
the National Grid has said that we're
fairly secure we have a buffer and it's
very unlikely uh to use their words that
we won't have enough electricity this
winter but of course if if you're out
and about and you're not at home then of
course turn the heating down or off some
people can't afford to put it on in the
first place
um but if we're not concerned about it
unnecessarily then why are you advising
people not to use as much electricity
well that that's only from an
environmental point of view rather than
a rather than a security one the the
government is is
pretty confident that we have enough
energy to get us through this winter
we're feeling quite fortunate compared
with some of our European friends in
that regard and
we if if we need to give more messaging
later on in the winter then we'll do
that but at the moment what is important
is that we help people to understand
that there is enough energy they should
use it if they need it and if they're
old or vulnerable and sitting at home
then they should put the heating on of
course they should Nadeem zahawi who
describes himself as the Chief Operating
Officer for the government was on the TV
yesterday saying we should go to the
government website to look for advice I
went and I feel it actually it's not
straightforward
um I filled in quite a lot of questions
and the outcome was that I needed to buy
35 000 pound heat pump was it yes was
this a was this a an attempt to get you
to be in more more environmentally no
idea but that's what it was suggesting
that I should do in order to try to save
energy but there you go the 12 to 37 000
pounds depending on the ground source
and and went further into it and it said
about 35 grand for my heat pump well I
mean clearly that's not an option that's
available to everybody I mean it may be
I don't know how you answered the
questions or what sort of house you live
in but um we do need to look at new ways
and new Renewables to heat our
properties I don't have a heat pump I'm
still on oil I'm afraid so I think at
home we we will be a bit more sparing we
will be a bit more mindful but I've
tried for years to to get the children
to be more mindful about the energy they
use if I'm honest a lot of people
um are on benefits
um and would not be able to afford that
sort of money or indeed to put the
heating on at all over the winter period
and and yet the prime minister is
looking at or being told not increasing
benefits by the rate of inflation I'm
guessing you would implore to think
again on that well no decision has been
taken about the upbrating of benefits
this is a a it's quite a long and and
prostrate process driven decision-making
and and if I could just explain it to
you so tomorrow we'll get the September
figures I know it's October but they
come out tomorrow on earnings next week
we'll get the figures on inflation and
then the Secretary of State my secretary
of state at the department of work and
pensions has a statutory duty to
consider those figures you can't do
anything until those figures have come
and she will then consider how to if at
all operate benefits and what figure to
choose she has a very wide discretion to
do that we make a decision and we
communicate it usually by the end of
November and then I will take through a
piece of legislation in the House of
Commons which happens every year in
January and then benefits will be up up
rated or not or in in accordance with
whatever the method is chosen in April
but as if we know which we do according
to research that's been done if we don't
increase it by inflation benefits 450
000 more people were going to absolute
poverty I think it's a no-brainer I
think it's really important we have all
the statistics and all the figures about
poverty as well at our disposal before
we make this critically important
decision it's obviously a really
worrying time for people on benefits
because they know that inflation is
rising and they want us to make this
decision as soon as we possibly can so
that they have the security of knowing
how their benefits will be next year I
get that completely but I can't possibly
make the decision and on my own now we
need to get the figures get everything
at our disposal and then I will make
sure that we make that decision as
quickly as possible yeah but it's going
to cost 5 billion pounds if you go with
inflation how will you pay for that I
think um the difference between between
the two figures wages or inflation is
about half of that in fact
um so but obviously it depends on what
those figures are but we'll know a lot
more next week I think it's really
important that we make sure that we
target the government resources at the
most vulnerable this winter um okay talk
to me about the SNP if you would it's
their conference at the moment in
Aberdeen and Nicola sturgeon says she
detests everything the Tories stand for
how do you feel about her well I don't
think that's great language to use and
actually frankly when you look at the
global situation we're in and the war
that we were just talking about I really
think it's quite important that we're
able politely to disagree with each
other in this country we are so
fortunate we can have a democratic
system so much that we take for granted
and we ought to be able to have sensible
discussion about policy without
detesting each other there's no need
okay politics of the playground well I
it's just not how we do things I don't
think
um talk to me about some suggestions in
the newspapers this morning that I'm
reading that Tom Watson should be given
a peerage that was knocked back a couple
of years ago but secure starma is
looking again at uh Tom Watson getting a
period what do you think
well it's a matter for the labor party
who they put forward for parentages
well I've never really I I'm I'm not the
world expert on that story I know that
there was there was well let me tell you
yeah yeah yeah he he um had been accused
um or he his he has now been insulting
the victims of false sex abuse
allegations
um lady Britain as in um yeah his widow
branded Mr Watson despicable and
defensive as you know he was falsely
accused of rape and child abuse as a
result of this uh campaign that had been
conducted at the time
um Harvey Proctor falsely accused of
being a child murderer by this fantasist
as well supported by um Tom Watson
should he get a peerage well the my
difficulty is Kate is that I I don't
know what Tom Watson believed I don't
know I I'm really can't advocate for him
in any way he was clearly taken in by
somebody who was making up very
unpleasant and and malicious stories
about prominent men at the time what Tom
Watson believed at any one time I really
can't so you wouldn't it wasn't
something that you would say well I
think it's very important that anybody
who gets a period should be very
carefully investigated and I do think to
go to your earlier point that it is
quite important that we're very careful
in public life about who we accuse of
what yeah
um so everybody should be thoroughly
investigated before they get a period
what about Conor Burns
I don't think there's any suggestion
that Conor Burns is getting a period
yeah there is yeah yeah there is
um yeah apparently um his name is on the
list that um the former prime minister
has put forward uh well I haven't heard
that what do you think should he get one
um I think where we are what's happened
I I don't know any more about that well
I probably know less about the facts of
the incident than you do I think what's
important is that the chief whip has
been asked to investigate this I think
that she must do that as quickly and as
thoroughly as possible it's a really
difficult situation for all involved not
least
um the the accuser the the victim the
alleged victim if you like and I think
it's really important that we we solve
um this particular problem as quickly as
we can before he gets the Knighthood
what is impressive is that the Prime
Minister took very Swift action she did
to make sure that that Conor was removed
from office while the matter is
investigated but I think from his point
of view as well as anybody else involved
we just need to get on with working out
what happened the young Ukrainian girl
that lives with you what's her name
thika okay well we have another Victoria
yeah we hope she's okay she's
um
it's
it's a great privilege having her to
stay actually
um but we do feel the war is very close
we must let you go thank you very much
indeed for joining us Mr President thank
you a quick look at the papers for
United here on Sky starting with the eye
reporting Liz trust will encourage her
party to put on a unified front as polls
continue to show labor far in the lead
the express our story Rebels to stop
plotting and show loyalty with the
picture of the business secretary Jacob
Reese mogg
the times says the Prime Minister has
begun a charm offensive to try to shore
up her party
but the guardian reporting her MPS are
keeping up the pressure to force her to
raise benefits in line with inflation
the Metro describes Russian attacks on
Ukraine after the strike on the bridge
linking Crimea and Russia as the wrath
of Putin
Telegraph reports Putin describing the
attacks as an act of terrorism by
Ukraine
ft reporting on the U.S treasury
secretary Janet Yellen saying Opex moved
to cut production is unwise
the mental leads with claims
universities are changing the way they
teach several subjects
and the mirror reports The Man convicted
of the acid attack on the TV presenter
Katie Piper is on the run and the sun
says the next series of the crown is
likely to prove controversial unlike the
others as it shows Prince Philip
pursuing an affair
we were talking about that winter
blackout where we're warning with the
minister there but will it mean refiring
up our coal-fired power stations in
order to cope with the energy crisis uh
shiman is uh with us now she's at
Greenwich power station which used to be
powered by Cole and is now gas hello
good morning to you
um what's the latest Where You Are
good morning Carrie well as you can see
the power station behind me and as you
rightly said used to be powered by coal
but it's now used as a sort of backup
power plant for uh TFO in case there is
an entire or partial loss of energy
provided by the National Grid but this
is kind of a poster child of the type of
direction we wanted to go in using more
low carbon energy Supply however we are
now being warned it's this a new report
from the National Grid it's highlighted
that some contingency plans may have to
be put in place in order to meet some of
the demands this winter so it could mean
more of the coal power stations being
opened back up again now we only
actually have a couple of them left in
the country one of them being in
Nottingham showing another one being in
North Yorkshire so it could mean opening
them back up and this is quite worrying
especially for climate change protesters
and climate change activists this coal
is not the type of direction we want to
go in it burns way more carbon dioxide
than oil or gas which is why we had been
phasing them out in the first place now
it is important to remember that both
the National Grid and the government
have said that blackouts are unlikely
but the National Grid are worried enough
to have contingency plans put in place
including ones like these
okay thank you thanks a lot
show these pictures that are just
reaching us here at Sky Center situation
developing in Ukraine limited
information at this stage but we can see
thick black smoke there rising in the
distance in Kiev when it's black smoke
like that it means that the fire is
still raging
um we are being told that there are
injuries and deaths we have no idea at
this stage what has happened the city's
mayor Vitali Klitschko saying there have
been several explosions in that District
of Kiev which is in the center of the
capital this involves this is after I
should say
um President Putin referring to an act
of terrorism in his words a bridge that
links Crimea with Mainland Russia that
has been severely damaged in places
after some explosions over the weekend
call that an act of terrorism here
speaking with his security
team and Personnel later on this morning
we'll get more information on that and
of course update you but these are the
latest pictures that we are receiving
from Kiev where Paul's of black smoke
arising into the morning Sky there
also still to come on the program as
taiwan's President says the country will
bolster its defenses and the tensions
with China I'm going to be speaking to
the Island's Deputy foreign minister
maybe Shadow Minister for mental health
that's Dr Rosanna Alan Khan will be with
me shortly after eight
and as the government opens up further
oil and gas exploration to help with the
energy crisis asking the former
permanent special representative on
climate change sir David King how it
marries with our environmental goals
convicted swindler Anna Sorokin has
spoken to the New York Times but her
hopes to remain in the city despite the
risks of deportation for years she used
the same she used the name Anna delvey
to pass herself off as the wealthy
daughter of a German Diplomat and her
case became the basis for the popular
Netflix series inventing Anna she was
released on Friday to house arrest after
serving three years in jail for conning
250 000 from Banks hotels and Rich New
Yorkers
this is what she told the New York Times
they denied bail before it was an
exercise in perseverance so many
immigration lawyers tell me I'd get
deported to Mars before I get out in New
York she went on to say letting them
Deport me would have been like a sign of
capitulation confirmation of this
perception of me as this shallow person
who only cares about obscene wealth and
that's just not the reality
in other news police are searching for
the man who threw acid over the
television presenter Katie Piper after
he was recalled to jail for breaching
his license conditions Ms Piper was left
fighting for her life back in 2008 when
Stefan Sylvester threw acid over her
face in a targeted attack arranged by
her ex-boyfriend she suffered
significant injuries that left her
permanently scarred and blind in one eye
Stefan Sylvester was given a live term
in 2009 for the attack he was released
in 2018 after serving a minimum term of
six years in pres in prison Sylvester
fled after being recalled to jail for
breaching those conditions
not a probation service spokeswoman said
we are urgently working with the police
to bring the offender back to prison
where he'll face longer Behind Bars
okay we're just uh some more breaking
news before you've just been telling
what's been happening in Kiev and
explosions there where we're told
injuries and death now hearing about
explosions in leviv that is to the west
of uh donipro that's according to the
Reuters news agency so that's within the
last few moments we're also hearing
about explosions in leviv as well as
those explosions and fires in Kiev
um we'll get more on that and update you
further
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you know and a 22 year old
woman who was killed in a hit and run in
Shropshire has been named as Rebecca
steer the steer and another pedestrian
was struck by a vehicle after it mounted
a curb outside a restaurant in oswestry
early on Sunday morning she later died
in hospital the 28 year old man has been
arrested on suspicion of murder
hundreds have gathered at vigils across
Ireland in memory of the 10 people who
died in an explosion at a petrol station
in County Donegal a five-year-old girl
who was buying a birthday cake for her
mum
was among the victims her father was
also killed another victim Jessica
Gallagher is being remembered as an
up-and-coming designer with her whole
life ahead of her
she just turned 24 last week or two
weeks ago and she was gone on to do
fashion in Belfast she just got a new
job Belfast
and she was going up yesterday but
unfortunately with the gas explosion she
wasn't able to make it
new research suggests thousands of
children in England and Wales are
receiving poorer quality School meals
due to food shortages and Rising prices
a survey which represents School Meal
providers found organizers organizations
rather are using more processed food and
are considering switching to imported
meat to cope with Rising costs
we recognize that this is the one hot
meal that many children get and whether
they're receiving a universal infant
preschool meal a preschool we're already
buying a meal this is an opportunity to
do that in a school setting where
they're where they're where they're safe
where they're ready to learn so the
meals that are being provided are
healthy and nutritious but they're not
where they could be if funding was
addressed to deal with the issue
now here's something you may be able to
relate to new research showing that more
than two-thirds of us experience the
so-called Sunday scaries is the feeling
of anxiety about the week ahead as many
of us face stress in the workplace it
comes as the World Health Organization
Issues new guidelines for employers to
provide help here shingy
Lauren's life is full of color
she runs an eco-friendly glitter
business and loves her work
things haven't always sparkled
her old job as an air host desk left her
tired depressed and drained
this is how she felt at her lowest
before leaving last year
it got to the point where I would do a
really long day flying and every day for
about two weeks I got home and I just
sat on my bed that exhausted I couldn't
even get out of my uniform and just sat
there crying I was making myself ill
from stress from work
she says her employers failed to support
her through difficult moments like the
death of her best friend and her mom's
cancer diagnosis making long grueling
days even harder you know when you've
lost somebody you want to go and support
your family and be there for them but
you can't do that you need to put on a
smile and a brave face and deal with
hundreds of people in a day in a metal
tube in the sky where you've got no
Escape
new figures show those feelings of
dreading a job are common
the research reveals 67 of British
employees experience anxiety about the
week ahead
the top triggers are work stress at 72
percent lack of rest and sleep also at
72 percent
and their to-do list for the week ahead
at 70 percent
they also found that 53 of people feel
anxious about working in person compared
to six percent of people if they're
anxious about working from home
statistics like those are why the who
has laid out new guidance it includes
training managers to support staff and
advice on helping people come back from
mental health related absences
if you support effectively the mental
health of your Workforce you are not
losing out on productivity losses not
losing out on where people reach a point
where they have to take absence because
they're not doing as well that's really
important and also you're retaining your
staff
it's about the finer details focusing on
how every person feels at work will make
the difference
Sky News
well if you have been affected by the
issues raised in that piece are in need
of mental health support contact the
charity of mind for help you can reach
them on
mind.org dot UK and don't forget of
course you can always reach out to the
Samaritans they are always there for
you'll get the number on the screen
coming up for you in just a second quick
look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
mostly fine a couple of days after the
southeast dries up this morning rain in
the Atlantic for late on Tuesday
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
some of the photos that I've caught are
I this morning for you Joshua's put them
together a full Hunters Moon Rises over
Dover Castle in Kent as the first full
moon of October the moon appears much
bigger and more orange than normal now I
want to say Hunter's moon is that when
there's two any in a month can't
remember I know what somebody will tell
me uh tweet me if you'd like to at Cape
early this picture is taken from the
opening night of the hull Fair one of
the largest traveling fairs in Europe
which features over 250 rides
for Ferris wheels amongst them and a
stunning view of the sailing boats
participating in the 54th edition of the
traditional Barco Iana Regatta and the
Gulf of Trieste in North East Italy it
was also a dog that I'd seen in one of
the papers I don't know where he is but
he'll be here for the next hour now as
taiwan's President says the country will
bolster its defenses amid tensions with
China going to be speaking to the
Island's Deputy foreign minister coming
up very shortly
latest situation in Ukraine there have
been several explosions heard in Kiev
and also live if we are being told by
the mayor of Kiev that Vitali Klitschko
that there have been some deaths um
talking tomorrow's Theory as you can see
we're talking to the the minister and
she's actually looking after some
Ukrainian families at the moment she was
very alarmed by what was happening
that's right a lot of MPS are actually
hosting Ukrainian families I spoke to
some at the conservative conference and
of course they know that it may be a
long a long haul because many of the
Ukrainian families here will not be able
to go back anytime soon because of the
the terrible events there and just one
of the the many challenges for Liz truss
how how on Earth the the West End ends
this sees this conflict going on of
course she's promised made a huge
promise in her leadership campaign to
put three percent of our GDP of our
national income into defense because
said the West was asleep at the wheel
about Russia and a threat it posed and I
think as she makes difficult decisions
along the line not least about benefits
and many of her MPS will want to hold
her to that one and we're asking
actually about benefits to the minister
this is what she said
no decision has been taken about the
upbrating of benefits this is a a it's
quite a long and and prostrate process
driven decision making I think it's
really important we have all the
statistics and all the figures about
poverty as well at our disposal before
we make this critically important
decision it's obviously a really
worrying time for people on benefits
because they know that inflation is
rising and they want us to make this
decision as soon as we possibly can so
that they have the security of knowing
how their benefits will be next year I
get that completely but I can't possibly
make the decision and on my own now we
need to get the figures get everything
at our disposal and then I will make
sure that we make that decision as
quickly as possible
will the minister there describe the
decision on how much to raise benefits
by next year as critically important and
critically important not just for the
millions of people who rely on Universal
Credit many of whom are working but also
for the Prime Minister herself after she
made that U-turn on cutting the top rate
of tax for the wealthiest people it gave
many in her cabinet and on her back
benches the feeling that they could now
get her to cave in on more now Liz truss
has never actually said publicly I don't
want to raise benefits by inflation but
we know that that is something that's
been discussed in government as a way to
save money to pay for some of these tax
cuts she's now under great pressure I
understand including from senior figures
in her cabinet to raise benefits by
inflation next year the minister
revealed it's the end of November we'll
find out thanks very much tomorrow while
the president of Taiwan has been
speaking this morning to Mark the
Island's national day saying that a war
with China is absolutely not an option
joining us now is taiwan's Deputy of
foreign affairs minister Dr zai Ming Yen
hello to you Doctor thank you for
joining us
um what do you think is going to happen
next in this incredibly tense situation
uh yes I think we will understand that
the Chinese Behavior are becoming more
and more aggressive and provocative so
China not only sends its military
aircraft to intrude into taiwan's ill
Defense Zone but also carry out for a
big scale or military exercise along
Taiwan in this August so we believe
China's final objective is to alter the
status quo of this region and to show
that China is becoming a predominal
power it is part of the world under the
strong leadership of Chinese leaders Xi
Jinping so what China is currently doing
is to you know carry out all kinds of
rehearsals for military options against
Taiwan and then to test the bottom line
of our Global community so what I'm
telling you is that China is used in
Common Street as a playground and the
Taiwan has become a fun life State
against the China's expansion so how to
take to the uncertainties and problems
caused by a powerful and aggressive
China has become so challenging not only
to Taiwan but also to so many countries
around the globe and the region okay and
we have been hearing um
that Chinese Fighters uh their their
fighter jets uh that intrude taiwan's
airspace will be regarded as a first
strike
um does Taiwan currently have the
military capability to prevent
a first strike or indeed an invasion
yes first of all uh which they are very
high alert um all kinds of military
activity or movement taken by China and
secondly we have been making enabled to
give up our defense capacity for example
in next year taiwan's or defense budget
will be increased by about 14 and a lot
would account for about 2.3 percent of
our GDP so we have been making every
effort to improve taiwan's long-term
military stress so as to increase the
potential cost for invention from the
other side of the Taiwan Street and the
priority of our defense monetization go
to our summer rainforced air defense
system in South Falls and the promotion
of the integration between our civilian
society and the defense sector so the
message is that we would like to send is
very clear like is Taiwan is not
intimidated and the taiwan's future and
democracy can never be decided or
dominated by chance military activity or
military program
tomorrow
um I think it's tomorrow uh the national
holiday of Taiwan a military parades
planned all sorts of celebrations in
that regard
how are you going to ensure that China
doesn't see this as provocation
uh yes I think um Taiwan has been uh you
know stick to the principle to uh you
know maintaining the state school in the
town street and the light is a common
ground the life is a consensus reached
by our society and that's the reason why
because taiwan's a policy toward China
has been so predictable so we have been
receiving uh increasing support Upon Our
International friends so if you look at
United States has been taking a very
important role to group like many
friends like uh us India
Japan and Australia a new mechanism
called a squad to promote the you know
diplomatic Corporation to check and
balance the you know Chinese behavior
and not based on their trust to taiwan's
policy that is very predictable and very
stable
okay good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you pleasure thank you
for turning now to the war in Ukraine
and the U.S President Joe Biden has
warned that the conflict has raised the
risk of nuclear Armageddon to its
highest level since the 1962 Cuban
Missile Crisis joined Now by a Dr Robert
Bell who's previously worked as defense
advisor at NATO and also the U.S
National Security Council during Bill
Clinton's time at the White House it's
good to see you thank you for joining us
on the program this morning let's just
talk about that language that we heard
from uh Joe Biden was that appropriate
language at the moment
I think it's entirely appropriate that
the president remind us that these
Stakes are very high
that uh President Putin's language is is
totally Reckless at the same time it's
also important that he remind us that we
We have dealt with nuclear intimidation
before
and the societies have to be prepared to
steal their resolve if you will in the
face of such threats we cannot just
simply be intimidated
um yeah but but is it not escalating the
wall by or the threat of uh war and
nuclear attacks by using words like
Armageddon
Armageddon is a term that I think almost
everyone Associates with nuclear weapons
there's not much dispute on this
President Putin himself joined president
Zee and President Biden and Boris
Johnson and Emmanuel macron at the
beginning of this year the leaders of
the permanent members of the security
Council put out a joint statement saying
that a nuclear war could never be won
and must never be fought
uh that hearkens I think to the scale of
catastrophic damage that would follow
from a nuclear war that escalated to a
general Exchange
happening if you would please
um in uh Ukraine this morning uh we're
hearing that there have been explosions
in uh Kiev and also in leviv this
follows the attack on the bridge between
Crimea and Russia over the weekend we're
hearing from the mayor of Kiev and he's
saying the capital is
excuse me the capital is under attack
from Russian terrorists the Rockets hit
objects in the city center the air alert
and therefore the threat continues I
appeal to all residents of the capital
to stay in shelters during the alarm if
there is no urgent need it is better not
to go to the city today we were starting
to get the impression that things were
getting back to normal in Kiev that is
clearly not the case this morning
oh well the Russians have a limited
supply of long-range missiles that they
can shoot in from sanctuaries either to
the East and the Don bass or from over
Russia and South of the Black Sea
clearly President Clinton has used to be
President Putin has been terribly
embarrassed by the attack on the Kirch
Bridge he also has a new Commander for
the overall or Air Force General sorry
Beacon and between the two of the new
Commander wanting to show that he's
going to be tough President Putin
needing to show the Russian people that
the Kirch Bridge bombing is going to be
revenged someone made a tactical
decision overnight to launch a wave of
precision strikes into major cities and
that's extremely tragic for the
Ukrainian people
it's also part of the Russian Playbook
as as War has progressed we're becoming
almost uh immune now to the reality that
Russia's only card they can play is to
strike these civilian Targets in urban
areas
so you see this is a direct retaliation
for what happened the the attacks in
Kiev this morning direct retaliation for
the images that we're seeing now of the
coach Bridge connecting Crimea to Russia
yes and to the disadvantage of the
Russians assuming that Ukraine's morale
holds which I assume it will because
their supply of these weapons is
dwindling and they really you would
think logically would save those for
important military Targets this Terror
bombing of cities they make the Russians
feel better but it's not
helping them defeat their Ukrainian
counter-offensives at all
we know that President Putin is meeting
with his security Personnel later on
today I'm sure we'll hear more about
that in the fullness of time he has told
us several times now that he's not
bluffing
um what is your view on someone who say
who has to tell you that they're not
bluffing
well he has said from the beginning that
he is totally serious about this going
back to February 24th he said there will
be severe consequences if anyone
interferes with my operation in Ukraine
we clearly in the west have interfered
with this operation with Weaponry with
intelligence with sanctions so we have
in effect called his bluff for seven
months he's now trying to be more
explicit
I think it's conceivable if he felt he
had no other options left that he might
be insane enough to use a tactical
nuclear weapon but I don't think he
thinks he's lost yet he has a new
Commander he's done a partial
mobilization winter is coming he has
doubts about European resolve given the
energy situation so I think the chances
remain low sitting here in October it
could be a different situation come
spring or summer
we um are just hearing very emotive
words from president zielinski he says
if if you if I could just read it out
for the benefit of you of course then
also our viewers
um it's via the official telegram
account
the 229th day of full-scale War
on the 229th day they are trying to
destroy us and wipe us off the face of
the Earth
in general destroy our people who are
sleeping at home in zapparitzia kill
people who go to work in denipro and
Kiev the air alarm does not subside
throughout Ukraine there are missiles
hitting unfortunately there are dead and
wounded please do not leave shelters
take care of yourself and your loved
ones let's hold on and be strong that
from president zielinski what more of
anything can NATO do to try to help the
people of Ukraine
well I think NATO has pushed the the
sanctions button about as deeply as you
can push it perhaps a little bit more on
the energy side uh trying to get India
and China to help us with the sanctions
would make sense particularly in the
face of this Russian Terror bombing on
the military side we're up to very
highly capable weapons now that we're
providing the only thing that's not been
provided is the modern fighter aircraft
are deep strike ballistic missiles
I don't see the West going to boots on
the ground or no fly zone yet but if
there were a nuclear use I think either
of those options would certainly be
considered
good to talk to you thank you for taking
the time to join us thank you bye the
leader of the lib Dems and I said Dave
of course is with us now I'm sure you're
monitoring events in Ukraine this
morning good morning to you sir Ed what
are your thoughts
I think all our thoughts and prayers are
with the people of Ukraine I think the
words of presence lensky there really
sum up the issue
um the ukrainians have been brave and
courageous throughout this uh the UK
with our NATO allies have been
supporting them fully and and I actually
strongly agree with our government in
the work that we have done to support
the ukrainians um but we need to need to
be there the whole time we need to be
with them until they succeed and drive
Russia out of their country
um we know that there was an attack on
the bridge between Crimea and Russia at
the weekend was that totally appropriate
uh listen I will allow the ukrainians to
decide what they think is the right way
of fighting this war I'm not going to an
armchair General in London what I do
know is Ukrainian ukrainians had their
country illegally invaded by a nasty
dictator and we need to be behind them
this is yes it's a fight for the freedom
of Ukraine but it's a a fight for
democracy around the world uh if we were
to allow uh Putin to get away with this
uh appalling Invasion another country it
would send all the wrong signals across
the world whether to China or elsewhere
it's absolutely essential the fight for
freedom and democracy that we stand
shoulder to shoulder with Ukraine the
whole way through this
um talk to me about matters at home we
know that the government is thinking
about what to do as far as benefits are
concerned whether they should increase
in line with inflation or whether it
should be real-time wages
um we're now being told we would
originally told that they looked as
early as trust wanted to go with the
letter of the two options were now being
told that no decision has been made
um is that pressure from back benches do
you think
well I hope so but I think the
government needs to think about the
millions of people out there who would
be struggling even more if they failed
to take this policy you know I go around
my constituency and talk to people who
are in work but require support from
Universal Credit I talk to people who
are on disability uh benefits
um real people who are struggling
already struggling frankly more than
they've had for had to do for many years
if the government was so hard-hearted
not to break benefits by inflation I
think that would be a social catastrophe
and look what they're doing at the same
time they've talked about tax cuts for
the richest people now they may have you
turned on that they're still giving huge
tax cuts for large corporations much of
which is going to the big Banks they're
refusing to bring in the windfall tax uh
a proper windfall tax on the uh
unexpected High profits of the oil and
gas companies this is a government
that's completely out of touch with
what's happened in our country they've
got their priorities wrong what liberal
Democrats are saying is we need to
support people out there who are
struggling struggling families we should
do that as our top priority we shouldn't
be thinking about tax cuts for the
wealthiest and for the biggest
businesses
Nicola sturgeon says that she detests
Tories and everything they stand for do
you
I wouldn't use that language my view is
that liberal Democrats want to get rid
of the conservatives as liberal Democrat
leader my top priority is to defeat as
many conserved MPS that the next
election as possible the conservatives
are taking people for granted in their
consistencies they either don't get
what's happened to people or don't care
and this out of touch government has to
go and so liberal Democrats are are
striving every sinew to oppose this
appalling government and put forward our
constructive alternative positive
policies you know we were the first
party to argue for a windfall tax so we
could raise the money in a responsible
way to help people struggling with fuel
bills and we will continue to oppose the
Tories and put forward strong
alternative policies okay we're almost
out of time but I do want your opinion
on this
um should either Tom Watson or Connor
Burns get knighthoods
neither
thank you very much for joining us on
the program
thank you let me update you on what's
happening in Ukraine should I add the
229th day of full-scale war is how
president zielinski has described it on
his official telegram page he goes on
let me read it to you on the 229th day
they are trying to destroy us and wipe
us off the face of the Earth in general
destroy our people who are sleeping at
home in zapparitzia kill people who go
to war in dinipro and Kiev the air alarm
does not subside throughout Ukraine
there are missiles hitting unfortunately
there are dead and wounded please do not
leave shelters take care of yourself and
your loved ones let's hold on and be
strong and this is in relation to
incidents over the weekend in zapparizio
where people died and these are attacks
that we've seen in the capital of Kiev
this morning
we're not sure of the number although we
have heard from uh mayor Klitschko he
says there are injured and dead as part
of these attacks on Kiev this morning
they've also been attacks in leviv as
well being told that there are certainly
casualties in the Viv too all of this
has come after the coach Bridge which
connects Crimea just open a few years
ago Now it connects Crimea to uh Central
Russia this happened to it over the
weekend just watch these pictures there
you go parts of it have been severely
damaged no one has yet claimed
responsibility but the Russians very
confident that Ukraine has carried out
these attacks severely damaging this
bridge it would certainly be fair enough
to say that the people of Ukraine are
not content with this bridge these are
the latest pictures that we're just
receiving now from Kiev where we are
being told my goodness me where we are
being told that there our deaths and
injuries as a result of several attacks
this morning we are also hearing that
President Putin will be speaking to his
security Personnel later on today we'll
hear the very latest on that when we can
but more deaths in the capital of
Ukraine Kiev